uh conan worked for nbc and i worked for
nbc and so
we crossed past a number of times we
lived in the same neighborhood
he's you know uh
he's so very talented he's he's just
and i'm sure you you know this and
people know this but well i was on conan
before
yeah he's so quick yeah he's funny he's
quick he's harvard educated he's like
he's
he's just he's humble he's got all those
incredible things together and so
he understood when i had done his show
before i was like i don't like talking
about me and so he or we would come up
with some kind of
gag or some kind of prank that i pulled
on the show we and he would air it
at one point we did i showed him how to
browse like
a craft service table that was a segment
that we did ended up with somebody
getting shot
but you know he was like you want to do
comedy let's do comedy like he was game
for him that's cool
it was incredible you know yeah go ahead
we were doing that thing
and uh we were going to promote the show
and i'm ready to go and then there's the
knock on the door
and i think it's the segment producer as
you know that's the person who comes in
and goes hey michael so remember we're
going to talk about this
this this this and going to walk you out
to the stage
and there's a knock on the door and i
think it's a segment producer but it's
michael roush the show runner
and uh michael goes uh michael goes
so they pulled us i'll never forget the
intonation i'll never forget the words
verbatim he goes so
they pulled us and we stared at each
other we're in the green room
stand at each other and then he kind of
closes the door we'll kind of look at
each other and then
and it's a knock and literally i'm
supposed to go
you know and and this time it's not the
segment producer
it's conan and conan goes
i just heard and i'm like yeah and he
says
and this is like one of those like
action movies where it's like 30
29 28 and he's like i totally get it if
you don't want to go on uh but you're a
double and i got nothing else a double
means like
we're gonna do a thing we're gonna go to
commercial break and then we'll come
back back and i'm gonna talk to you
again i've never been a double i'm a
single get out
get out and i'm like uh i'm like no i'll
go
and he's okay good and then they're
rushing us out there and it's like
five four he's like can you talk about
what just happened i was like uh
better not i don't know what i would say
that might be really really bad he's
like yeah yeah okay
and literally he's like dude and conan
is like hey welcome back and he's like
hey everybody it's like i'm here with
tom cavanaugh
so you bike right
and he's like
[Music]
the thing just sails by because he's so
funny and he's so quick and nobody would
ever have known
and then that summer i was doing year in
town he's like hey come back on the show
and he's like now can we talk about it
and i'm like yeah now we can talk about
it wow
the last time tom was here we see that's
perfect
he told the story and people in the
audience were like ah
oh yeah because he was like that's
hollywood
you know and yet even though it's like
the most
hollywood kind of bad bad hollywood
story i have
there's no intent like i say there's no
intent of evil behind it how how many
seasons did you do that was our third
episode
just three episodes in yeah and what was
it called
love monkey well i mean that's just
theft three episodes how do you know
anything
well do you hear about seinfeld you give
things a chance
this is the thing though i remember a
friend of mine
did a show called like uh i had two
friends and they both did shows
that were like on it and love monkey was
the same thing was on every so i live in
new york it was on every
bus every taxi cab and it was like they
loved it we shot
a full season and as you know
but maybe people who are listening don't
know they sh we shoot so many episodes
before we ever air them and so for a
while the only
um the only barometer you have
is is it good when it lands on your desk
and so you know i think that show
um you know that i think that that show
we were fine let me put it this way i
think we were
we were finding our way but the there
was something ephemeral about
judy greer was in the cast jason jason
priestley chris wheeler lawrence tate
um there were there was also there were
such talented
human beings in that show that there was
something ephemeral that translated from
that to the screen and we were finding
out how to
capture it and i think the the reaction
from the network was like this is great
you know i think they really did enjoy
it it was an
hour long that's trouble one about
um an a r music guy
in new york city so it wasn't blood and
semen for your hour long
you know it wasn't like it wasn't like
murder it was just like
you know it was it was human drama and i
think that's a big problem on a big
network and again like i say
not to offer excuses but that's an hour
of time
and if you can put csi on and double the
numbers
you're probably going to do that but
they were taking a shot with trying to
make the network a little younger a
little hipper and the new york pool a
little a
r all that kind of stuff some some so
a little bit of sex a little bit of that
kind of stuff and so
you can't blame them for taking a foray
to try and be more competitive with the
cool factor that at the time
nbc and fox and those shows
yeah so they were doing that but then
what's interesting is
um emily the reasons why not and then
the mike o'malley show
had happened just prior to that and
what's interesting is they were
plastered on every bus
as well and you'll probably remember
this oh yeah you were doing stuff at the
time
they were like the new big thing yeah
and
the amount of money that got sunk into
you know the advertising budget was was
astounding
and up until that those moments in my
experience anyway bridging both the
you know the analog and the digital of
all this kind of stuff there was a
there was a thing where like if you put
that uh
much money into promotion then you had
to go with the show and so famously
shows like cheers and seinfeld and
friends that didn't perform well
but had been promoted they're like look
you can't just yank it off the air why
because we'll look silly
and so they gave them enough time and
they had champions
tardikov and so on who were like no this
thing is good right
i put it on my desk i did the litmus
test the barometer was
it showed up on my desk and it looks
good so we're gonna stay with it for a
little bit
but with mike o'malley and with emily's
reasons why not
when they didn't perform numbers-wise to
what they'd hoped
they would get because of promotion they
took them off the air immediately i
think it was like one episode or two
episodes
at the time and there was no penalty
right there was no
backlash penalty to the networks and i
think that became
uh oh that's an mo then if we can
take them off and put on csi and
nobody's gonna
there's not gonna be backlash then
that's just what we're going to do